هنا في الجنوب الاوكراني وتحديدا في منطقه
خيرسون وقف الرئيس الاوكراني قبل عام يهدئ
من هلع مواطنيه جراء الاخبار عن الحشود
الروسيه على طول حدود البلاد
اليوم وبعد عام من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تعود الاصوات لتذكير الرئيس
الاوكراني بما تسبب به للبلاد ليس كمسبب
للحرب بل على تجاهله الاعمى للتحذيرات من
غزو روسي كان وشيكا ومن الاخطاء التي
اعادت البلاد الى ايام الحرب العالميه او
اسوا يتذكر الاوكرانيون جيدا كيف وقف
رئيسهم هنا يدعوهم لعدم الضعر كان ذلك قبل
ان تصبح المنطقه باكملها بيد الروس فيما
عدا المدينه
يجب ان اتحدث مع شعبنا كرئيس واقول للناس
الحقيقه والحقيقه هي ان لدينا معلومات
مختلفه لكن افضل صديق للاعداء هم
المذعورون في بلدنا وكل هذه المعلومات
تساعد فقط فيه خلق حاله الذعر ولا تساعدنا
نحن
وحكومته كان منشغلين بملاحقه الخصوم
السياسيين بتهمه الخيانه امر اثار استياء
الحلفاء الغربيين حينها وعندما بدات الحرب
لم يجد الاوكرانيون ما يدافعون به عن
انفسهم ورغم الحرب عاد الفساد ينخر حكومه
زيلينسكي وطفت على السطح قضايا فساد
مرتبطه بكبار مسؤول الحكومه والجيش اعترف
بها الرئيس في العالم
اليوم شهد الاوكرانيون مجموعه اخرى من
القرارات بشان الموظفين الفاسدين اؤكد على
اننا سنستمر في العمل على اي قضايا داخليه
تعوق الدوله الاوكرانيه من اجل الدفاع عن
البلاد والجهود المبذوله للتقرب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي رغم التاييد والتعاطف
الدولي لزلنسكي لا تبدو اوكرانيا بين حرب
وفساد باحسن حال في عهده ليس بسبب غزو
روسيا بل لان اداره لا تشبه التمثيل
والكوميديا وهو ما يقوله منتقد ومعارضوا
الرجل